ང་འདི་དགོས། ང་དགོས།
སྤྲད་(ད)། སྤྲད་(ད)། སྤྲད་(ད)།
འདི་ཆུང་ཆུང་། འདི།
མི་ཆེན་པོ་༼ཁ་གྱི་༽རེད་བས།
བསྟན་(ད)། འདི་བལྟ་ཨ།
བལྟ་ཨ།
༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽བྱས་སོང་།
བསྟན་(ད)། བསྟན་(ད)།
ཧ་གོ་་མ་སོང་།
སྦག་སྦག་བཏང་ད་པ་ལགས་གིས། ངའི་པ་ལ་༼གིས་༽འཆམས་འཆམས་ཁྲིད་སོང་།  ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ངའི་པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽ནང་ལ་ཁྲིད་བྱུང་། ནང་ལ།
པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽ང་ལ་ར་ཚལ་ཞིམ་པོ་འདུག་ལབ་སོང་། ཚལ།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། ངའི་ཨི་བི་སི་ཌི་སྦྱང་སོང་། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ང་(ར)། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ང་(ར)།
ག་ར་ལབ་དགོས་བས།
པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽ཚལ་དང་ཁ་ལག་སྤྲད་སོང་། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ང་(ར)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ང་སྐྱིད་པོ་་་ཟ་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས་༽ང་(ར)། ང་སྙིང་རྗེ་པོ་་ཆགས་རེད།
འདི།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽"པི་རྫ་"སྤྲད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ང་(ར)།
དོམ་གཅིག་སླེབས་རེད། དོམ་གཅིག
དོམ་ཆེན་པོ་ད་དོམ་ཆུང་ཆུང་ད།
དངོས་གནས། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽དོམ་གཅིག་ཞུ།
Dinosor ཆེན་པོ་་དཔེ་ཆེན་པོ་སླེབས་རེད་(ད)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཞེད་སྣང་ཚ་པོ་ཡོད་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽གླང་ཆེན་སྙིང་རྗེ་པོ་་་ཡོད་རེད། གླང་ཆེན་ཞེད་སྣང་ཚ་པོ་ཡོད་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽གླང་ཆེན་(ར)།
གླང་ཆེན་དེ་(ར)། གླང་ཆེན་པུ་གུ་ཆུང་ཆུང་དེ་ཡོད།
ཆེན་པོ་བྱས། གླང་ཆེན་སྙིང་རྗེ་པོ་ཡོད་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། Dinosor ཡོད་(བ)། ཞེད་སྣང་ཚ་པོ་ཡོད་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽Dinosor དེས་ར་སྦྲུལ་དེ་བསད་རེད། ད་ལྟ།
ཁ་སང་སྔོན་མ་ཡོད་(བ)། ཁྱི་འདི་མོ་ཊ་གིས་བརྫིས་རེད།
ད་ལྟ། ཁ་སང་རེད་(ད)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽།
ཁྱི་དེ་(ར)།
ཁྱི་ཕལ་ཟུག་འགྲོ་མ་རེད་(ད)།ཕལ་ཟུག་ད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽(ར་)ཁྱི་ཆུང་ཆུང་དེ་ཡོད་(བ)།
ཁྱི་ཆུང་ཆུང་དེ་སྙིང་རྗེ་བོ་ཡོད་རེད།
ར། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། Dinosor ཆེན་པོ་དཔེ་ཆེན་པོ་དེས་སྦྲུལ་བསད་རེད། སྦྲུལ་ཟ་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽སྦྲུལ་གཡུག་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽སྦྲུལ་ཆུང་ཆུང་གཅིག
གཡུག་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡང་བསྐྱར་གཅིག་གཡུག་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽།
སྦྲུལ་དེ་ཞེད་སྣང་ཚ་པོ་ཡོད་རེད།
ཁྱི་དེ་སྙིང་རྗེ་པོ་ཡོད་རེད། སྦྲུལ་དེ་འགྲོ་བསྡད་ཡོད་རེད། Dinosor དེ་(ར་)ཆུང་ཆུང་ཡོད་རེད།
སྦྲུལ་དེ་ཆེན་པོ་་ཆེན་པོ་ཡོད་རེད། ཕལ་གཡུག་བྱས།
སྦྲུལ་དེ་ཡོད་(བ)། ཨ་མ་་ལབ་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽(ར་)པ་ལགས་ལབ་རེད།
སྦྲུལ་དེ་ཨ་མ་དེ་ཡོད་(བ)།
སྦྲུལ་དེ་ཨ་མ་ཡོད་(བ)། Dinosor དེ་ཡོད་(བ)། ཆུང་ཆུང་གཅིག་ཡོད་ཕལ་གཡུག་བྱེད་༼གི་༽ཡོད་རེད།
ཕལ་གཡུག་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ་)སྦག་སྦག་གིས་ར་སྤྱི་སྤྱོད་རླངས་འཁོར་དེ་ཡོད་(བ)།
མི་དེ་༼འ་གག་༽ཆགས་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། [པད་ཤག་]སྤྲད་རེད།
རྒྱ་གར་༼གི་༽[པད་ཤག་]གིས། རྒྱ་གར་ལ།
ད་ལྟ། ཁ་སང་ཡོད་(བ)། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽།
མེ་ཏོག་སྙིང་རྗེ་བོ་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)།
ཨ་མ་༼གིས་༽༼ར་༽སྙིང་རྗེ་བོ་འདུག་ལབ་རེད་གྲུ་ཆུང་ཆུང་དེ། པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽༼ར་༽པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽གྲུ་སྙིང་རྗེ་བོ་འདུག་ལབ་རེད།
གྲུ་ཆུང་ཆུང་དེ། པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽ཡག་པོ་འདུག་ལབ་རེད་ཇག་མ།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། བུ་མོ་སྙིང་རྗེ་པོ་འདུག་ལབ་རེད་ཨ་མ་གིས།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽རྔན་པ་སྤྲད་ད་ལབ་རེད་ཨ་མ་གིས།
ཨ་མ་ང་རྔན་པ་ཟ་ག་ལབ་རེད།
རྔན་པ་ཟ་ལབ་རེད་(ལོ)། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། ཨ་མ་༼གི་༽(ར)།་པུ་གུ་གི་(ར)། པུ་གུ་༼གི་༽(ར་)ཨ་མ་ལ།
Ice cream སྤྲད་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། པུ་གུ་༼གིས་༽ཚལ་ཞིམ་པོ་འདུག་ལབ་རེད། ཨ་མ་ཚལ་ག་རེ་བླུགས་རེད་ལབ་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད། ཨ་མ་༼གིས་༽(ར)། ཨ་མ་༼གིས་༽ཤིང་ཏོག་ཉོས་རེད། ཤིང་ཏོག
ཆུ་ག་གོན་ཡོད་རེད། རྒུན་འབྲུམ་ཡོད་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽གཞན་པ་རྫོགས་སོང་།
དུག་སློབ་བཀྲུ་༼ཡ་༽་སྐམ་ཚར་རེད།
ཨ་མ་༼གིས་༽དུག་སློག་༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽བཀྲུས་རེད།
པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽༼ར་༽གྲོད་ཁོག་ན་རེད་ལབ་སོང་།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)། པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽གྲོད་ཁོག་ཨེམ་རྗེ་ལགས་ལ་སྟོན་རེད་(ད)་ལྟ་ཨ་མ་གིས།
ཨ་མ་༼གིས་༽གྲོད་ཁོག་ན་སོང་ལབ་རེད། པ་ལགས་དང་ཨ་མ་༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)། པུ་གུ་༼གིས་༽གྲོད་ཁོག་ན་མ་སོང་ལབ་རེད། གྲོད་ཁོག་ཏག་ཏག་རེད་ལབ་རེད།
ཨ་མ་ད་པ་ལགས་ད་གྲོད་ཁོག་སོང་ལབ་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས༽།
ཁབ་བརྒྱབ་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་དྲགས་ཚར་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽སྦག་སྦག་བཏང་རེད། སྨན་ཟ་རེད་དེ་ནས་ཡོད་(བ)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽སྨན་ཟ་རེད། སྨན་སྨན་རེད་(བ)།
སྨན་ནང་ལ་ཇ། ཡང་བསྐྱར་སྨན་ཟ་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ་)ཆུ་བཏུང་། མིད་པ་བཏང་།
འདི། ༼འ་གག་༽བཏང་ཚར་(ར)།
༼འ་གག་༽བཏང་ཚར་(ར)། Dinosor དེས་གཅིན་པ་བཏང་རེད། བ་ཕྱུག་གཅིག་ཡོད་(བ་)གཅིན་པ་བཏང་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)། བ་ཕྱུག་གི་གཅིན་པ།
བ་ཕྱུག་གིས་ང་མཐོང་མ་སོང་ད་ལྟ།
༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽ལབ་༼གི་༽འདུག སྦེ་་་ལབ་༼གི་༽འདུག
ཁྲོམས་ལ་འགྲོ་མ་རེད།
ཨ་མ་༼གིས་༽ང་ལ་༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽བྱས་ར་༼ཨ་ནས་༽ང་མཐོང་མ་སོང་།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ང་ཅོ་ཅོ་གིས་(ར)། ཁྱོད་ཅོ་ཅོ་གྲོགས་པོ་ཡིན་པས། གྲོགས་མོ་ཡིན་པས། ཅོ་ཅོ་༼གིས་༽༼ར་༽ང་(ར)།
ball ་སྤྲད་སོང་། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ང་ཡོད་(བ་)ball རྩེ་ཡིན་(ད)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽སྒྲུང་རྫོགས་ཚར་སོང་།
གཟའ་ཉི་མ་ཡོད་(བ་)སློབ་གྲྭ་ལ་འགྲོ་ཚར་སོང་། གུང་གསེང་རེད།
ད་ལྟ་གུང་གསེང་རེད།
སང་ཉིན་གུང་གསེང་རེད། འབུ་འདི། འབུ་འདི།
ཨ། འ་་སྦྲུལ་ད་དགའ་པོ་ཡོད།
སྦྲུལ་ད་་
སྦྲུལ་ད་Dinosor། Dinosor ཆུང་ཆུང་རེད།
ང་Dinosor གྲོགས་པོ་བྱས་སོང་།
Dinosor ག་རེ་བྱེད་༼གི་༽ཡོད་ལབ་རེད།
ང་(ར)། ང་(ར)། ང་་་ང་ག་རེ་བྱེད་༼གི་༽ཡོད་ལབ་དགོས་བས།
རྔན་པ་སྤྲད་ད་ལབ་རེད།
པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽ང་ལ་ཁྱོད་ག་བར་ལ་འགྲོ་རེད་ལབ་རེད།
ང་འགྲོ་ཚར་ཡིན་ལབ་རེད། སྒྲུང་རྫོགས་སོང་།
ཁ་ལག་ཟ་ཚར་ནས་ཡོད་(བ)།
ཤིང་ཏོག་ཉོ་ག་འགྲོ་རེད། དེ་ནས་ཡོད་(བ)།
༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽བྱེད་ག བྱེད་ག
ཧོར་་་་ལབ་༼གི་༽རེད་(ད)།མེད། ང་ཚོ་ལ་སྦག་སྦག་མེད།
ང་ཚོ་ལ་ངའི་པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽མོ་ཊ་ཉོ་དགོས་ལབ་སོང་། ངའི་པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽རྐང་འཁོར་ཉོ་དགོས་ལབ་སོང་།
ངའི་པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽དུག་སློག་ཉོ་དགོས་ལབ་སོང་། ངའི་པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽རྩེད་མོ་ཉོ་དགོས་ལབ་སོང་།
ང་ལབ་དགོས་བས།
ང་ར་རྔན་པ་སྤྲད་ད་པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽ངས། ངའི་པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽འཁྱགས་པ་བྱི་རིལ་སྤྲད་སོང་།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)། ངའི་པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽ཤིང་སྡོང་ཉོས་སོང་།
ཨ། རྒན་བསྟན་འཛིན་ལགས་ད་རྒན་འཇམས་དབྱངས་ལགས།
རྒན་བསྟན་འཛིན་ལགས་ད་རྒན་འཇམས་དབྱངས་ལགས། ག་རེ་བྱས་ནས་ལབ་དགོས་བས།
རྒན་བདེ་སྐྱིད་ལགས་ད་ཡོད་(བ)།
གོམ་པ་བརྒྱབ་ནས་འགྲོ་རེད། གོམ་པ།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ་)ཚར་ཚར་སོང་། སྒྲུང་རྫོགས་ཚར་སོང་།
ཨ་མ་རྩར་ལ།
འགྲོ། Biscuit འདི་སུས་གཡུག་རེད།
རྒྱ་གར་༼གི་༽གཡུག་ཡིན་ས་རེད། ཨ་ཅག་[པད་ཤག་]སྤྲད་(ད)།
[པད་ཤག་]མེད་བ། རྒྱ་གར་ལ་སྤྲད་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
ད་ལྟ་སྤྲད་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན། རྒྱ་གར།
དགོང་དག་སྤྲད་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
རྫིགས་པོ།
ཟ་ཅག་ང་སྒང་ཕུག་དགོས། སྒང་ཕུག
ཨ། ང་ལ། ཨ།
[པད་ཤག་]རྫོགས་མ་སོང་། རྫོགས་མ་སོང་། རྫོགས་མ་སོང་། སྐུ་ཆེ་རྫོགས་མ་སོང་།
སྐུ་ཆེ་ད། ང་ལ་སྒང་ཕུག་དགོས།
འདི་དགོས་ངལ། སྒང་ཕུག་ག་བར།
ང་ལ་འདི་མི་དགོས།
ད་དེ་ནས་ཕལ་ལ་འགྲོ་དགོས། ཨ་ཕ།
ཨ་མ་རྩར་ལ་འགྲོ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན། ཨ་མ་རྩར་ལ།
ད་ལྟ་འགྲོ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན། ད་ལྟ།
ཨ་མ་འདི།
ག་འདྲས་བྱེད་ག་ཨ་མ།
པ་སངས་གཡུ་མཚོ།
ཨ་མ་ལགས།
ག་འདྲས་ཡོང་ག་ཨ་མ།
ཨ།
ཡོང་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན་སྐུ་ཆེ་ཨ་མ།
ཨ་མ་རྩར་ལ་འགྲོ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
ཨ་མ། གཡུག་ག་ཨ་མ། ང་ཉར་༼ཡ་༽མིན།
ང་འགྲོ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
ག་རེ་རོགས་པ། ང་འགྲོ་༼ཡ་༽མིན། ང་ཨ་མ་འགྲམ་ལ་བསྡད་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
ང་ཨ་ཕ་འགྲམ་ལ་འགྲོ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
ང་འགྲོ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
མོ་ཊ།
ང་རང་གི་ཨ་མ་རྩར་ལ་འགྲོ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན། ཉར་གྱི་མིན།
ཨ་ཅག་ཡག་པོ་ཞི་དྲག་མི་འདུག
སང་ཉིན་༼ཁེར་༽ཨ། ༼ལོ་༽
འདི་་
ཨ་ལ་ལ་ལ། ལ་ལ་ལ།
ཨ། འདི། འདི་བཟོས་མེད།
ག་བ།
ཡང་མར་ཟག་སོང་། ད་ག་རེ་བྱེད་ག ༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽བྱེད་ག
༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽བྱེད་ག མ་བྱེད་ག
ཨ་ཕ།
ང་ཚོང་ཁང་ལ་འགྲོ་ག
ག་བ་ལ། ཨ་མ་རྩར་ལ་འགྲོ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
ང་ཨ་མ་རྩར་ལ་འགྲོ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
ཨ།
ཡོད། ཡོད་་་་
ཨ་ཕ་ང་འདི་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་གས། ཐུགས་རྗེ་ཆེ་གནང་།
གྱིས་ད་ཨ་ཕ་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་དགོས། སྐུ་ཆེ་ད་ལྟ།
ད་ལྟ་རྩེ་གས། མི་ག་བ་མི་འདུག ག་བ།
གཙུག་ལག་ཁང་ལ། ཨ་ཁུ་དབང་ཕྱུགས་མི་འདུག་ལབ་སོང་།
གཙུག་ལག་ཁང་ལ་མི་འདུག